like every view commemorates robbed the
silver so we'll do this in your working
language which is English
excellent I want to show a picture from
your office because we got a picture of
a little sculpture that you have in your
office take a take a look at this this
is this is a little sculpture but it was
a it was a price obviously it was given
to me by someone who disagreed with some
of the things that we were passing in
government in Denmark but it is quite
well done it's a male hand it doesn't
it's soo well then but some someone who
didn't like yet maybe of this yes but I
like to have it in my office to remind
myself on a daily basis that someone
will disagree with me and someone will
strongly disagree with me no matter how
good a decision I think that that I take
no matter how much I care and make an
effort there will always be someone who
disagrees and I think it's a very good
reminder on a daily basis on an hourly
basis that no matter how high you have
climbed someone will disagree with you
and this is how politics works yes why
is it a problem that we have companies
now very popular very very much like
companies that are a lot bigger than any
state even than EU a lot more powerful
and it concerns it concerns all of us
well we should care because technology
is is not there for its own purpose it's
there for us and if someone becomes you
know the almighty having a a monopoly
having maybe 95% of all what goes on in
a marketplace you get a special
responsibility because the risk is of
course that you have higher prices that
you limit choice
that you stop thinking about what is the
next new thing and if we want to have
affordable prices and something to
choose from and someone to keep
challenging also the big guy
then you need competition and this was
what Google was closing down in what way
well they there is this quite amazing
operating system on most phones eight
out of ten phones globally which is
called Android it's open source that's
great but the thing is that you want the
out-of-the-box experience and you can
buy apps and you it works basically this
is what you want and Google set to phone
producers well you can have the Play
Store but you have to take Google search
and the Google browser so that things
become tied together and we will pay you
not to let anyone else in and we will
punish you if you do it anyway on just
one of your devices so it just became a
one-way Google Street instead of a new
experience so that we had something to
choose from so well obviously Google is
not here to defend themself but I wonder
are we are we sometimes as consumers
naive well I mean when when I when I
when I almost every day you get some
terms and conditions on your screen and
I mean I don't know do you do you read
it before you push agree sometimes and
very often I ask when I do a keynote has
any of you read to terms and conditions
no not really one have not really but
the thing is that we have gotten new
digital rights sort of citizens rights
the right to be forgotten
the right to well we do own our own data
but also the right to take him from one
provider and give them to another
provider but the problem is of course as
you say to exercise these rights we need
help
and we need maybe an independent digital
assistant that will help us so that we
are in control because our information
is is a value this is the this is how
they can do innovation this is what you
feed your artificial intelligence
morning lunch dinner data data data it's
all they eat so it's a big value that
you hand over whenever you do anything a
Google search shopping with Amazon
updating your Facebook page pushing on
an Instagram every time you create value
but you allow other people to use that
value to make money how much data do you
give away I have got no idea
unfortunately you just push I agree and
continue
it's it's so easy you know and for
example my granddad he uses also
technology and he gives me at least once
a day how does this work and I just
press ok just press ok and it will work
in the end I think one thing that one
could do instead of reading all that
stuff it is something sometimes to be
curious to test something new to test
for instance I'm testing another search
engine that will stop tracking so that I
don't leave a trail in my search I'm
just testing new things because we are
some degree lazy and convenient and this
is how we usually do those thing but if
we can do something else then more
people some of the newcomers they will
have a chance but you how I mean some
people mean are of the opinion that that
you in the EU by by taking on these big
companies also are protecting the
citizens of the EU and hence it's
protectionism the policies that do you
you're having and and that's accusation
I take very seriously because sort of
it's a very fundamental thing in Europe
that everyone is
treated equally so do they have give you
a US company European company let you
have the same so yes we're very very
careful and and the reason why they're
here is that they do a very good
business but it is important that
there's even better before you came but
the thing is that it's not just European
companies complaining it's also US
companies complaining about how other US
companies are behaving when in Europe
you are by some a much feared birth
person they don't want to have a phone
call from you how do you relate to the
power you have well um I try to be very
careful because power is a is a very
addictive thing and and it's a tool that
I have for lending for a limited period
of time so I try to say well it's not
about me it's not about me being a
wonderful person it's because they have
a job to do and yet at the same time I
think it's important to open up a little
to say who is this person that you have
given this tool to do this job because
the risk is that you think that it's
it's not about the job anymore but it's
about you and that's I think is that's
the most dangerous thing about power you
have to sort of keep a certain distance
yeah I do always I mean it's that
possible for you always so little do you
sometimes get this addictive I
I think I could you quit tomorrow and be
okay with it I think I would have the
worst possible hangar where ever
because I think one thing is that you
can imagine that you can sort of quit
from one day to another but I think if
it's if it's real it will be extremely
difficult because the thing is that when
you have the top job you're taller and
you really are you much more funny but
then you really are if you also have
people receiving with ten years ago in
in another job I would be absolutely
boring now only see me but this is
because that you have power people look
up to you they they are much more
attentive to what you say so it's when
you're going sort of leaving the power
tool behind you I think that would be
that there will be a hangover but you
you are I know as a politician it's
important for you to be to be a person
as well yes and to be visible as a
person as well how do you do that what
is the trick well I don't know if there
is a trick but what I try to do is first
of all I don't wear a uniform
what do you mean uniform I don't most of
the people I worked with the CEOs coming
into my office they would be men and
that's very strange thing because men
seems to like to wear the same clothes
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
but it seems that at a certain age and a
number of jobs men want to wear the same
clothes I don't know to be more
anonymous to sort of hide their real
personality you would know better you
are man it's a prison
it's a person I tell you yeah but where
we're stuck here no there's no me so I
don't want to wear sort of the the
female version of the suits I want to
wear dresses I want to wear color I want
to have pictures of my family in my
office instead of pictures of important
people I mean I want to be known I
wanted to be known that I like to do my
shopping that I knit that I like to cook
that I do things that everyone else is
doing that I have a life and Brussels
after all a bit boring isn't it it is a
secret but it's an amazing city it grows
on you
the French fries you don't get some any
better the markets
what did you say grandad who would take
a trip to Brussels we haven't
I'll put the kettle on for coffee it's
all we drink tea over weed oh I can
provide for that as well
wait wait where did you where did you
get your sense of justice wait where
does that come from but where I grew up
everyone was welcome because my parents
they were ministers in the Danish Church
both of them both of them yes so you
know maybe early morning we would wake
up because some various sort of
exhausted completely new dad would come
and say I had a child during the night
and people would come during the day for
maybe more normal business and maybe
like 11 o'clock in the evening the phone
would ring and one of my parents
wouldn't really have to rush to come
because someone was in need so everyone
was welcome everyone was treated the
same and that for me maybe was one of
the most important things when I was a
child that no matter what you do or
where you come from you're welcome are
you are you still a church church girl
yes they happens yes but you never
considered becoming a priest yourself no
if I were to have a motto it would be
trusting God and fear the church these
guys these guys are now going driving
through Africa which maybe think about
your elephants because you you that's a
hobby you have yes to knit elephants
why elephants well first of all it what
comes out of it as it's a small toy like
this so it's not a it's not a sweater
you know a sweater it grows and you have
to carry it so it's small handiwork and
the thing with elephants is that they're
very social they're living groups they
are led by females they tend to be very
friendly creatures and yet they remember
very well so evil is never forgotten
neither is kindness and that I find
that's a good friend to have so instead
of go buy something when someone is
having a child I tend to send them an
elephant so ideally one should keep an
elephant one of your knitted elephants
and this hand with the finger in your in
it here yes so then you realize that you
are always to be challenged but you also
realize that you will always have a
friend but you get the best are you
thank you so much hope you enjoyed the
clip for more interesting conversations
please hit subscribe